bernard hier te dis vive l'algérie oui
on l'émission franchement voilà états
unis mais s'il vous plaît tu as eu un
déferlement de haine
ah oui des monades variable qu'est ce
qui s'est passé aujourd'hui mais toute
la journée ça a été un déferlement
incroyable
je tiens d'abord à remercier alors il ya
eu des milliers et franchement des
milliers d amis ça de ma vie de gens qui
me disaient d'abord kim affirmé leur
soutien et qui m'aimait des coeurs c'est
très bouleversée aujourd'hui très ça
soit tu te sens vraiment très ému
bernard oui oui c'est très bouleversant
mais il ya eu des messages extrêmement
violent extrêmement violent genre quoi
quand vous va d'abord on veut me
décapité comme l'autre professeur qui
regarde
j'espère tu finiras décapité comme
certains parents français et là moi
aussi je dirais villes d'algérie sais
pas quoi c'est profondément choquant
alors je veux dire ouais je suis à la
fois blessé et déçu que l'on en soit
encore là notre époque si vous voulez
cesser de vivre ensemble gens ciblés
on essaie de vivre ensemble bon ils
veulent diviser les partis de jean
messier avait dit viser mieux sur aviez
hier c'était c'était de ça moi monsieur
ravier hier je lui ai rien dit de
spécial je lui ai dit j'ai été choqué
quand il parlait de monsieur benzema
mois benzema je suis ravi qu'il revienne
en équipe de france mais oui nous sort
attendait on nous sort et c'est
l'algérie le match et encore mais
arrêter quoi moi j'ai eu envie de dire
vive l'algérie parce que j'aime
l'algérie et les algériens comme je dit
vive la france
je suis français en plus je me suis
ravie elle pensait que j'étais algériens
alors envoyez vos camarades sont pas
très brillant alors je suis pas là
attendez je suis pas là je suis pas le
porte parole de ravier ce soir c'est je
suis pas là pour le défendre
je dis simplement que quand on a des
opinions qui sont les vôtres qui sont
affirmés il faut souffrir
effectivement ce genre de choses sur les
réseaux moi personnellement ça fait des
années que je suis menacé jauzion et des
préalpes sinon merci pas ça c'est que je
reçois des messages pires que ceux le
pire que celui attendu alors là à
pleurer son bien mais c'est pas ça le
faux lac métier mais river de sa mère
vous aussi moi je suis un homme de dix
maires de maintenant mais si je prône
reamonn mais c'est quoi un veillant
tolérance excuses moins tolérants
bernard excuse moi à partir du moment où
tu expriment une opinion politique ce
que tu as fait effectivement il faut
accepter les tic grise algériens bien
sûr il faut accepter pourquoi il faut
attendait
dans le débat qui avait hier par rapport
à benzema etc tu été confronté un
politique
apolline exavier c'est un politique
donc toi tu étais là pour le contredire
donc tu as un message qui contredit le
sien et donc par définition que
politique
donc si tu s'il est effectivement tué
quelqu'un de fragile qui n'acceptent pas
ce genre de choses pas dit ça faut
rester en tout cas il faut pas venir
s'exprimer politiquement j'ai choisi
c'est bien jean montiel qu'on a invité
soit juste un mot ces crimes moi ça fait
quatre ans que je subis ça je n'ai
jamais eu le droit à une émission je
n'ai jamais eu droit à ce salaire
dérisoire des messages comme on vient de
le faire ce soir
rien à voir toi tu viens tu as droit au
retour ça va bien qui je pense moi je
pense pas marcher sur la personne je
pense à tous les gens qui me tous les
jours sans insulter sur les réseaux
sociaux qui reçoivent des menaces de
mort mais vous aussi pourquoi pas bon
non mais bon dans son boudoir rendent
assez de morts quoique ça je vous ai mis
dans le groupe ou ses râles et un hub
est hâtif n'ont pas vraiment il ya des
gens qui méritent la vingt dix ans ne
cherchez pas les citer mais pas des
autres
c'est fou l'issue de l'arrêté des
méharis
on